I think a lot of people take issue with
the term Survivor because okay Survivor
is like you know you survived a building
collapse you survived a murderer or you
survived yeah and and you know survive
means to live like it it I guess I
suppose I would Define it as living
through something which may have taken
your life you survived it's uh you're a
survivor of a shipwreck so I guess the
question is and I'm not saying it's not
true you know for a lot of these women I
could imagine that they do end up dead
especially when it comes to the more
serious international trafficking yeah
they'll get they get forced onto drugs
into opioid onto opiates because it'll
make them more manageable and then many
of them do die from this my my concern
is I I wouldn't I wouldn't say based on
the accusations on the entertain thing
it's probably iffy I think the issue is
a lot of leftists a lot of woke people
will call themselves survivors when it's
like someone said nasty things to them
or like they got into a fight in the
street you know what I mean